he was expected to win and he did now
our campaign is not just about beating
Trump it is about transforming this
country
it is about having the courage to take
on Wall Street the insurance companies
the drug companies the fossil fuel
industry the military-industrial complex
Vermont senator Bernie Sanders takes the
most delegates in New Hampshire not far
behind former mayor of South Bend
Indiana people who to judge a relative
newcomer so many of you decided that a
middle-class mayor and a veteran from
the industrial Midwest was the right
choice to take on this president not in
spite of that experience but because of
it these were not the expected
frontrunners but with former Vice
President Joe Biden and senator
Elizabeth Warren faltering new faces
came to the front voter said that was a
big reason so many were undecided up
until the last minute some of the
frontrunners I'm not sure I think their
ideas are good but I'm not sure they
have the right path and they have the
right ideas so I think that's why people
are now leaning this way and kind of at
this last minute like this is a strong
possibility coming in third another
unexpected candidate moves to the front
of the pack Minnesota senator Amy
Klobuchar I'm Amy Klobuchar and I will
beat Donald Trump New Hampshire is
important for momentum attention and
money raised it's clear tonight from the
numbers that we are not going to win
this race two of the lesser known
candidates quit after this vote but all
of the top contenders said they were
staying in it ain't over man we're just
getting started you still have 98
percent of our delegates for our
nomination up for grabs and Americans in
every part of the country are gonna make
their voices heard in exit polls
Democratic voters made clear their
number-one priority is finding someone
who can beat Donald Trump but they're
split on the best way to do that from
the far left or the center leaving New
Hampshire it's still not clear which
camp will win in the end patty :
al Jazeera Manchester New Hampshire